how's the gum run on it welcome back to
another episode of the safe Pig
so a lot of comments have been saying
that the next part is gonna be the most
[ __ ] up part so I'm wearing my tights
and might let their spandex go back home
it's late to go back home before your
parents find out and ground you son of a
which way is it I gotta say it's a real
pleasure to play this game play brothers
oh it's a lot of fun this game they
really nailed it I hope it like comes
out in seasons and and stuff that'd be
really [ __ ] cool
there you are [ __ ] we've been looking
all over for you you are grounded mister
right on home and go to sleep I wonder
if my parents are June I want you to go
to bed and think about what you've done
[Music]
honestly like this is day and age it's
not even bad being grounded I would love
to [ __ ] be home in front of the
computer where did everybody go man is
everybody dead I'm riding an epic we
don't care what is this well I guess we
have to go to bed huh don't tell me that
frickin my little gumdrop hope you're
enjoying all the peace and quiet in our
new home as much as we are
mother [ __ ] is she so nice I bet dad is
hitting all my curls I guess we gotta
kill what maybe they were a little bit
more discreet it would well we got
anyone plagues of Egypt summon chop all
right let's do that in any order why
does he let him well let's try the
plague of Egypt again when the light is
upon you
okay that's not too bad what the [ __ ]
what is happening yeah I don't like this
I don't like the aisle god I don't have
any Amman and gotta get my peepees
redbull oh [ __ ] yeah
I really wonder what all that cut what
is it oh yeah that one sucks sling of
David for life nugget let's get this guy
out of the way science [ __ ]
link up David is the [ __ ] man
let's do something I got [ __ ] all right
I miss what come on that's sorting too
bad either
[Music]
let's lift this load come on new quest
defeat all the underpants gnomes all
right awesome
cat wait so something really [ __ ] up
is gonna happen here according to you
Bruce I'm really curious get through the
wall space
let's investigate here more oh that's
[ __ ] she budding ahead come on we go and
it's it makes it makes a lot of
difference if you prep all the [ __ ]
things I think my bow is pretty outdated
but circumcised is Right belly I can
relate to this I mean watch no worries
no helmet I have to wear that all right
I think we're good let's [ __ ] know
this why the hell was that I could have
killed him in so many ways GG Pitts
gg idiot what's gonna happen here I just
sometimes feel like we should tell him
the truth
why so we can relive it all in his head
it's better that he can't remember but
if he really has this gift he's going to
discover it again on his own anyway and
then they'll try and use him for his
gift and he'll become a weapon they
won't stop looking for him we have him
that much everything secret even from
him I'm so frazzled will you just make
love to me they're gonna [ __ ] on me of
course I will darling
I know I just know it they're always hit
on each other okay thank god they're not
gonna [ __ ] on each other I mean nothing
alright well
I mean okay now let's go
i frickin noise in the background man so
okay now we max out these I guess we max
out this one can I even upgrade it no I
can't I need 11 all right
that's capable s into not what's here
thought that doesn't look good
let's check here no again all right
let's go gnome closed so what am I
supposed to do
[ __ ] noises shut up okay I got it Oh
No what the hell is up with his goddamn
right
[ __ ] off my god yeah but there's three
of them I better act swiftly and Geoff
oh whoa what hello what that did the
trick
[ __ ] what is this now don't do that
don't regenerate rate buffs what no
that's cheating man oh well I'm gonna
drink a Red Bull just cuz that it
doesn't say it's Red Bull but I red
balls yes of course what else will they
be
well technically isn't it made out of
like apples Tom wanted nothing okay well
let's say if we can knock one of them
yeah [ __ ] it might as well debuff them
you see my ears [ __ ] perfect blockage
blockage ah watch that baby goddamn it
do a lot of damage
I wish spiders were here to hear me I'll
have some cookie that's second size no
[ __ ]
[Music]
hello upset he always looks like when
he's got a second sight like alright I
don't do this [ __ ] alright it's my turn
again
cuz he's loaded that's awesome I don't
know why I wasted whoa why did he do so
much damage on him a thousand five
hundred
hey I'll take it so awkward listening to
this in the background I swear to God
[Music]
come on I said oh you [ __ ]
yeah call me [ __ ] just did you dirty
little [ __ ] yeah real dirty [ __ ] want
to see me in the panties and
[Music]
damn that attack may hello
I'll take it oh [ __ ] so much damage well
that was easy math spell is awesome
let's [ __ ] sound goddamn you're gonna
break her vagina man I would be a little
concerned
maybe I should sing the licen
[Music]
like a little look what is it gonna do
with him
no not today son
perfect pitch perfect pitch I'm a circus
eyes circumcised your dick [ __ ] oh
[Music]
thank you little [ __ ] yeah me about how
did I use single David I see if this D
puffs or some [ __ ] yeah that's cool
[Music]
what Oh No
Oh for [ __ ] sake that's a real matrix
oh my god oh no firepower a fabulous
he's so easy to block
I got kitty oh I get good I get the boss
guy I'm glad I got okay I'm glad I got
the boss i'm got him he got to Teddy
when I got the goddamn balls it was all
a dream
it was a horrible nightmare I would
seriously hope it was in a dream because
then my imagine you'd be completely
[ __ ] up okay so I can go in these
holes now is that is that part of the
process okay
sure why not so what I'm told is that
the main quest is only half as long as
[Music]
the actual main story and I feel like I
really want this game to to last a while
so I think I'm gonna do all the side
quests for sure I think if they're
worthwhile you know III don't see why
not
it's really it's not like we give a [ __ ]
about the main story damage general I
just like to see what the hell they're
gonna come up with in in this game and
there seems to be some your gate thanks
pal all the Warriors are called - okay
go to the forest
you [ __ ] humans and elves of Sauron a
great evil has descended upon us after
researching last night I believe we are
facing a threat to our entire world five
fortress of darkness is over four
stories tall
so far he has recruited at least 50
warriors to be on a team something to
say wizard yeah nothing just think it's
kind of funny how dry waves in the
Middle Ages can use power point darkness
I believe he is messing with something
he cannot control he has recruited many
of our friends and so our only hope is
for our two factions to join forces but
that we do not team up with [ __ ] else
you got a better idea wizard fat-ass
after what you have get us at the Battle
of horns Lee woods you think we'll ever
twist you yeah you tell the butter that
back was Jimmy's fault and he apologized
oh oh we're apologizing now how about we
apologize for breaking the rule about
using arcane fire magic yeah hey that
was the humans rule not ours join forces
my pelleted ass oh my good elf is a get
out why don't you suck my elven dick
buddist humans are gonna matter one bit
if all of solid is taken over by German
zombies we saw what that green stuff
we better figure out a way to stop Clyde
or there won't be a world to fight in
even if we join forces we don't have
enough warriors
so we recruit more affections to join us
the Pirates Federation and the girls
play with us yeah dude we can't convince
girls to do this no but maybe the new
kid can when you can't have the power we
have yet to understand he makes friends
on Facebook faster than any way of seen
he is really good at getting Facebook
fans I'll give him it find a way to get
the girl to side with up commander news
back I'll deal with the other factions
the rest of you return to your stations
and prepare for war
[Music]
awesome so now we mean okay I got ya I'm
right behind him I don't understand only
ideas friend because we need to work
together okay talk to Annie why the
girls is that it let's check out some
shops and show you know we elves craft
the finest [ __ ] in the land should
probably get that one right I'll get
this one
I said house should be here somewhere
yes [ __ ] yeah what is this the boys want
us to play with them I can take you to
the girls but I don't think they'll be
very willing to play with boys do you
wish to speak to the girls now well why
not come hi
meeting of the girls is hereby called to
order
sparkle Sparkle sunshine sunshine
Sparkle Milly Larson has the floor if it
pleases and sparkles I move that we vote
immediately on the urgent matter
involving Monica Ryland excuse me I'm
sorry but I have an urgent matter that I
believe needs to be addressed first the
chair acknowledges Annie sunshine
Sparkle and Enix has the floor if it
pleases and sparkles a messenger comes
with a request from the boys what
request do the boys ask of us he doesn't
really talk the boys are playing some
new role-playing game and the new kid
here wants us to join his team what we
don't have time for that something very
big happened and we must do something I
know I thought maybe he could help oh
that's not a bad idea i glitter Annie's
idea sunshine Sparkle emotion has been
glittered to have the new kid help with
Monica Ryland all right new kid look
there are terrible rumors going around
town that our good friend ally Nelson
was spotted at the abortion clinic I
have never been to the abortion clinic
I'm not a [ __ ] right you think the
girls spreading the rumors about Ally is
Monica Ryland and then she has the gall
to act all nice to me we have to know
for sure if Monica Ryland is a two-faced
[ __ ] or not so we're gonna send Monica
a Facebook page with your picture then
tell her that your baby's boyfriend from
Lakewood and you want to meet her and
ask her what the best thing to get baby
for her birthday would be and see if
Monica tries to hit on you at all
because that way we can see if Monica is
a manipulative [ __ ] right right
do this task for us and the girls will
consider your request sunshine
what did you just follow any of that cuz
I share is out that you'll find Monica
waiting for you at the park all you have
to do is pretend to be Bebe's
long-distance boyfriend but the job is
done come see me
[Music]
did you get any photos we've been trying
to infiltrate the girls baseboard yes
okay
hope you brothers enjoy watching I love
[ __ ] you playing this game the game is
awesome leave a like if you're watching
Bros have satellite and it makes you
feel a little better in the button
alright somebody love you back
[Music]